hey guys how's it going i want to do a
quick tutorial today on just how to make
a like a grid
system on unreal this might have
multiple parts but this is something i
couldn't really find
good documentation on so i just had to
figure it out the hard way i've been
getting into unreal it's been a lot of
fun so
let's get started i'll just walk through
it so of course you just launched the
engine i'm using the latest as of today
and once you launch it you just open it
start a new project i'm going to start
from blank just to keep it super super
simple and straightforward and we'll
just leave it all default
of course name yours whatever you want
or this you know you should be able to
integrate this into a current project if
you want
and i'll just walk through it and we'll
just we'll just get a little grid system
going
so we've got this opening starter level
which doesn't really have
anything we're just going to make a new
level so let's go
just right click down in your little
content area
make a new level i'm just going to call
it a
grid world or grid level
open that up and it's just blank so
first thing we're going to do in here is
we're going to give it some sort of
light so i'm just going to drag in a
directional light
that way we can actually see our grid
when we hit play
and we're going to make a few things
here for our
grid so there are a lot of different
ways to do this but the way i like to do
it is i like to make a little module
that you can drop
into any level so to do that we're going
to make a blueprint of just an actor
class
and we're just going to make this we'll
just call this like grid
placer sounds good so we'll double click
on that open it up
i'm going to dock it here and all we're
going to do to this grid placer is we're
going to add
a script so on this event graph we'll go
to the event graph here on begin play
we're going to make a grid and to do
that we're going to hold like
let's say we want to do like a bunch of
planes in an x
y type fashion so we'll just have you
know like a bunch of little squares
and however we want so we're going to
hold a few variables for how many we
want
and change this to integer
and we'll have like a width
and we'll also make another one called
uh
depth not really going to worry about
height in this case
although technically you could have the
some height ones but i'm just going to
keep them all the same height so
no z z is just staying the same and
these i got to hit compile i'm going to
i'm going to put them at five width and
depth of five
so it'll be a five by five grid is what
i'm going for here
and now when we begin play
we just want to enter a double for loop
to place these so we'll go for loop
uh yeah just a for loop here
and we'll make this one for the width
so starts at zero ends at width and in
this body we'll make another one for the
depth
so another for loop
and this one's going to be for the depth
and then every time we go through this
what we want to do is just
make a new grid piece spawn actor
spawn actor from class so we need a
class we could just say like a cube
uh it doesn't seem to have that though
so we need to make something for it to
actually spawn here
so we're going to flip out of this
blueprint and uh make something it's
going to have an error that's fine we'll
come back to it so let's go back here
let's just make another blueprint
and this one is going to be we'll just
make it another actor we'll just call
this like a grid
section so we'll open that up
and let's add maybe a plane yeah we'll
stick with planes
so yeah we'll just make it a plane
system
and they're just going to be white tiles
but if we wanted to
let's see we could make it look a little
better if we have something that where
we could kind of tell the border of each
of them so i'm going to do that real
quick with
[ __ ] so i'll just open up [ __ ] here
okay now that gimp's open we're just
gonna create a new
maybe you already have a material but
basically all i'm gonna do is create a
little a square object
so i'm going to go up here to
uh
gradient then we're gonna change this to
square and we'll give it some sort of
thing like maybe this blue green yeah
do a gradient fill uh that doesn't
really look too great
maybe we'll do this burning paper one
okay that's not bad we'll try to get
this right in the center
and now you can really tell it like if
each plane was textured like this you
could really see where the edges are
and that's kind of the point here all
right that's not too bad
we'll do it in a little more maybe
and you can do all sorts of things to to
do this however you want i think that
looks okay
i will really be able to tell with the
sections pretty nicely there i feel like
so let's go with that so make sure that
locks in
file export as
and i'm just going to keep it somewhere
where i can find it i could go straight
to my project
i'll just name this uh grid
grid text and i'm going to save it as a
bmp because i don't care about opacity i
just want it to be small
so i'm going to change this yeah 24-bit
bmp is fine here
and looks good so now we can close that
and uh i want to go back to here i need
to import it
so uh we're going to just find it on our
desktop here and drag it in
so just open your folder drag it in and
you can right click it
and create material and
that's fine name and it'll make a
material out of it so that's what you
need
so now we can go back to our grid
section and uh just find
a material for it uh we'll find grid
text matt there it is and boom there we
go
now we have a little bit of a border on
it
so we'll just save that and now we're
back to our grid
placer and now we can choose the
grid section grid section and it looks
like it needs some more things it's
going to tell you it does need a spawn
transform now this is where it goes
and we're going to use these loops to to
make something uh we left that plane
default size
which is i believe 100 by 100 in
unreal size so we need to
make them each 100 apart wherever we
place them so we're going to do a make
transform for each one of these so every
time it goes through this loop
we're going to make a transform so we're
going to click onto this
location here right click it split to
pen
struct and we'll drag in this index so
as it goes through this loop we'll make
it the x
and as it goes through this one we'll
make it the y but we need to multiply
by 100 so i'm just going to make int
times int and look for integer times
integer
put 100 on one side of it here
and this is now going to have to go to
here and this is going to go to
here and we no longer need this
node that we first created so i'm just
going to
copy control c control v
the same thing here so we're going to
times whatever the index is by 100 and
there we go
so also if we look at these four loops
they are less than or equal to
so it's actually going to process this
this last one
and going from 0 to 5 while processing
the last one will actually give us
6. so if we actually only want to place
5
we could either start this index at 1 or
we could make this
end at uh minus one
so however you want to do that i like
starting a zero so i'm just going to
minus one then
like so and i'll just copy paste
and that's just because how these
default for loops are
and you can just double click to look at
them they're just additional blueprints
all right and then we take this return
value of this transform and put it into
this spawn transf
transform and that should be enough once
we compile this hopefully it gets rid of
the error yep it does
so that is going to place us whatever
the size of these grids are
trying to get it all on screen at once
and there she is in case someone wants
to pause and look at it
it's the begin play and there she is
all right so save that again make sure
it's saved
okay so on this grid level now all we
got to do is take this placer
and just throw it in there and we got a
light we got a placer
uh we don't have a character for this
level so if we like go to this level
save if we go to world settings we need
a game mode
that's just part of unreal i don't know
i don't have a really character since
it's an empty project there's no
character or anything so i think it's
just going to give us like a
flying camera which is fine for looking
at it
so it might be a little easier if you
have a character and you spawn it above
so that it falls on your grid
but if you want to edit how that grid
looks and how it goes you can just go
back to the grid sections
in the viewport and then change these up
a little bit however you want
so i could do like a sky
we'll just do a sky so we can actually
sort of tell where we are there we go
so there we go there's a there's a grid
so if i
if i just change it if i edit my grid
placer and change these
we'll see that the grid will grow
there we go i think i did 9 and 18 there
hit play
there's a bigger grid and as you can see
i can't just fly through it
all right well that's how you just do
some general gridding stuff let me know
if you want me to go further with this i
probably will i might do two or three on
gridding i might get a character and
start like
doing some tracking where you're at on
the grid that sort of thing
because i know like grid combat is super
popular
and that's kind of what i want to do
i've been working on a little game where
i wanted to do
grid combat and i couldn't really find
much in
way of the tutorials on grid combat so
i just started figuring it out on my own
and this was like the first step was
actually getting a grid to place
all right we'll see in the next episode
peace out guys